[Musique]
le Nunavut est devenu cette semaine la
première juridiction à l'extérieur du
Québec à offrir toutes ses places en
garderie à 10 dollars par jour un jalon
important les provinces et territoires
se sont engagés à réduire de moitié les
frais de garde d'ici la fin de l'année
pour offrir toutes les places du dollars
par jour en 2025-2026 après avoir
financé le programme de garderie le
gouvernement Trudeau entreprend
maintenant des consultations pour
établir un régime national de repas en
milieu scolaire j'en ai discuté avec la
ministre de la Famille Karina gold
Kareena Gaulle de bonjour merci d'être
avec nous
vous avez annoncé que toutes les places
en garderie réglementées où nous n'avons
à l'aide dorénavant coûtait 10 dollars
par jour c'est un moment important pour
votre gouvernement ça oui tout à fait
alors comme vous savez nous avons énoncé
dans le budget 20 21 à une programme de
30 milliards de dollars pour en effet
réduire les frais Adidas à jour pour les
garderies des petites enfance dans les
prochaines 50 ne vote c'est le premier
qui va atteindre cet objectif la cible
c'était d'atteindre 50% d'ici la fin
2022 afin 2022 c'est dans un mois est-ce
que la cible va être atteinte oui ça va
être atteindre le pays de l'autre tout
le monde souhaiterait avoir une place en
garderie à 10 dollars en Ontario le
bureau de la responsabilité financière
dit que d'ici 2026 il va manquer 220 000
places en garderie Vous faites quoi pour
combler ce vide là parce que au-delà de
transférer ou de financer des places en
garderie encore faut-il en créer
davantage oui bien sûr alors avec notre
initiative nationale de garderie nous
avons commis à créer 250
000 nouveaux places de garderie
exactement
signé avec Ontario ils ont commis de
créer 86
000 en place ça va rendre dans le pays
une
presque 59% des enfants couverts mais
quand même
les provinces et territoires comme
l'Ontario peuvent aussi mettre leur
propre argent pour justement atteindre
ses buts et nous avons vu d'autres
provinces et territoires qui ont mis de
leur propre argent pour justement avoir
des sites plus hautes que nous avons
signé avec des provinces et territoires
où est-ce que vous en êtes sur les
places les frais de garde avant après
l'école parce que ça aussi ça coûte ça
coûte cher ça c'est pas réglementé en
fonction de votre programme non le
programme est vraiment ciblé sur la
petite enfance alors les enfants au
moins de 6 ans mais on entend rien par
exemple parce que le Kinder commence au
4 ans et à 5 ans alors les espaces
d'avant et après l'école sont couverts
jusqu'à 6 ans
mais nous savons que il y a encore plus
de travail à faire mais je crois que
c'est une excellente début c'est la
première fois que nous avons cette
plante nationale au Canada quelque chose
que était
en demande pour plus de 50 ans à ce pays
nous avons eu l'exemple exemplaire du
Québec à cet égard et maintenant les
familles du partout au pays vont en
avoir une réflexion de frais j'aimerais
qu'on parle d'une autre initiative vous
avez lancé des consultations mercredi
pour l'élaboration d'une politique
d'alimentation dans les écoles dans la
tête de Karina gold qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement qu'une politique
d'alimentation dans les écoles vous
allez servir des repas aux enfants
comment ça fonctionne le Canada c'est le
seul pays du G7 un des seuls pays
ont développé qui n'a pas une programme
une politique nationale des repas
scolaires et on sait si à ce pays un sur
ça un sur enfants va à l'école sans
avoir mangé un sur cinq alors nous
savons que ça a une grande implication
grande impact sur leur santé sur leur
capacités d'apprendre et bien sûr sur
leur futur alors pour moi c'est une
question
d'assurer que nous donnons le meilleur
départ dans la vie ou tous nos enfants
dans ce pays et le gouvernement fédéral
peut travailler en partenariat avec des
provinces et les territoires comme nous
l'avons de faire avec les garderies la
petite enfance pour justement appuyer
nos enfants donc c'est comme un espèce
de Club des petits déjeuners national
c'est ça vous pourrez être nous avons
beaucoup de différents programmes dans
les différents provinces et territoires
mais nous avons lancé les consulter
consultations justement pour écouter des
gens écouter des élèves écoutez des
familles des personnes qui sont engagées
dans ces programmes pour dire qu'est-ce
qu'on veut comme comme Canada comme pays
pour assurer que nos enfants on accède à
du bon et du Seigneur c'est tout ça et
de juridiction provinciales et
territoriales jusqu'à quel point est-ce
que vous êtes en mesure d'après vous de
faire avancer ce dossier là d'obtenir
une entente de la part de tous vos
partenaires me dire ça vaut la peine
d'aller dans cette direction voilà moi
j'ai eu des excellents compensation avec
mes homologues à provinciales et
territoriale comme j'ai mentionné chaque
province et territoire à quelque chose
mais il a vraiment des programmes
différents partout au pays nous avons
l'île de près après cette Word qui a une
programme universel de petit déjeuner
déjeuner à chaque école et il y a des
autres provinces qui a peut-être des
programmes de snack alors il y a une
grande variété ce que nous voulons c'est
de voir plus d'égalité dans le pays
parce que c'est une maman importante
nous savons que la vie est vraiment
haute l'inflation joue une rôle sur la
côte de la nourriture alors il y a une
maman maintenant je crois où il y a une
volonté avec les provinces les
territoires et le gouvernement fédéral
de travailler ensemble je reviens un peu
à ce que je disais au début dans votre
tête l'idéal ce serait quoi qu'est-ce
qui commence à se déclinerait
qu'il y a des petits déjeuners et aussi
une repas chaud pendant la journée c'est
important et c'est ce que nous voyons
dans les autres pays du G7 de l'octet
qu'ils font et c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est important pour nos enfants
on a parlé garderie on a parlé de repas
à l'école mais on vous a beaucoup vu
depuis quelques mois pour parler de
passeport
ça allait pas bien les passeports en
début d'année ça va comment maintenant
voilà ce qui se passait pendant le
printemps et l'été avec les passeports
c'était un excusable c'était vraiment
pas acceptable mais je peux dire à ce
moment que nous sommes dans une
meilleure voie c'est beaucoup plus mieux
c'est beaucoup mieux dès le début
d'octobre à nous avoir retourné au
service normal avec les passeports les
personnes qui se présentent un bureau de
passeport peuvent recevoir le passeport
donc à 10 jours les gens qui l'envoient
par la poste en 20 jours nous avons
embauché presque 900 personnes délaiées
qui ont vraiment aidé avec le capacité
de processus les passeports et nous
sommes rendus à une moment où nous
sommes en train de processer plus de 90
le passeport à la semaine merci beaucoup